hello good morning everyone
now yeah you're probably asking yourself
you're probably asking yourself what's
Steve doing with Moses's hat on I mean
not that that would be a good a good
question to ask what is Steve doing with
with Moses's head on so yeah I'm gonna
tell you I'm gonna tell you why I have
Moses has had on I was sitting reading
check in the Sun with this hat which I
bought when I was in Palm Springs I
bought the hat to keep the Sun off my
head and neck Sun the Sun is really warm
in Palm Springs it rains here in
Vancouver but it's sunny in Palm Springs
and so I was sitting there reading check
and I said hey hey I've got Moses his
hat on it's just my opinion but I
thought that if I had Moses his hat on I
should I should try to do a video where
I act a bit like Moses so so I thought
about it and and yeah I thought I would
I would just do that do a video do a
video where I sort of act a bit like
Moses not not completely like Moses but
yeah I think it's a good idea to do that
and and I'll tell you why because Moses
Moses has his style you know I mean I
have my style
Moses has his style and I think Moses as
a style is a very good teaching style so
yeah I'm a fan of Moses so I thought I
would pretend that I'm Moses and why why
is his teaching style good like why is
his teaching style good I'll tell you
why his teaching style is good because
I've has seen his teaching style before
and yeah there are a number of reasons I
mean it's just my opinion but why do I
think his teaching style is good we have
to adjust a few things here on my desk
just to kind of keep up the Moses style
here but his style is good because he's
a good communicator he he has a style
where he tells you what he's gonna tell
you then he tells it to you and then he
tells you what he told you so to speak
in other words he delivers his message
two or three different ways all around
the same theme and I think that's very
effective I remember you know i remember
when i studied cantonese yeah when i
studied cantonese i used to listen to a
guy on the local cantonese radio this
guy on the local Tampines radio had a
nice deep voice and he would talk about
politics in china but he would speak in
Cantonese cuz he was Cantonese so he's
gonna speak in Cantonese and he would
always tell us what he was gonna talk
about tell us what he was going to say
then he would say it then he would ask
himself a few questions and then he
would tell us again what he had just
said and I think that's very effective
because I think the brain learns slowly
and the brain doesn't learn from fact it
reminds me of when my wife taught our
in the local community college she began
full of you know enthusiasm and she
taught so many things that the students
didn't understand anything different
techniques you know because she's she
can do
oriental painting so she was teaching
them too many things at once and they
didn't learn anything then when she
slowed it down and taught only one thing
at a time and went over it and taught it
again then people learned and they
learned an awful lot more that way and I
think we learned better from examples
and stories and repetition that's how we
learn and not from some very tight you
know deep explanation however brilliant
it may be I think we learn from stories
and examples and Moses does that very
well I've always thought that he also is
obviously someone who is interested in
his students and so and he's patient
which is not something that I always
bring to the table so I think he's an
excellent teacher and he has his style
and and I'm not sorry to disappoint you
I'm not going to change my style to
become like Moses everyone has their own
style everyone contributes I think we
also Moses and I have different
approaches to to learning languages he's
learning Czech I'm learning Czech I saw
his video the other day his use of
different tense forms in Czech is better
than mine no question it may be that I
know more words than he does I don't
know that but that's where I put my
emphasis is on listening and reading as
I've said before you know and I've said
this before language learning is such a
personal thing we we do what we want to
do we do it the way we want to do it and
we can all share our experiences but
there are certain common themes and
certain common themes you know it's just
my opinion but yeah whoa there's a
common theme here and what is the common
theme motivation and time and a good
method but there might be several good
methods so if you're motivated and if
you put in the time and if you're happy
with the method you're using you will
succeed you will succeed and I'm also in
a way one of the reasons why I'm doing
this video is in a way in reaction to
the television program that was on
Canada's global television network which
seemed to imply that language learners
are a little bit strange people who
speak a lot of languages are a little
bit strange
Moses speaks an awful lot of languages
he speaks a lot more languages than I
doing maybe he's stranger than I am but
I don't think so
I think we're capable of learning many
many languages Moses will be the first
to admit that if he spends six months on
Estonian and six months on long and six
months on check
he doesn't achieve the depth of someone
that's been four years on Chinese but he
does pretty well at those languages and
I don't know if Moses is left-handed or
musical or has an immune deficiency but
in this program they suggested that
people who were into speaking multiple
languages might have something different
with their brain I don't believe that
and so this is the other thing I think I
think ordinary people like Moses like me
like others that I have met who have
motivation and spend the time and find a
method that they like so that if they
enjoy doing it they'll continue spending
the time they will all succeed some
might be better in pronunciation some
might learn some things a little
faster Moses seems to pick up the
structures faster maybe I'm picking up
vocabulary faster maybe I'm not I don't
know but it's our own thing Moses
success doesn't make my learning
activity less enjoyable Luca Luca who I
think is the champion when it comes to
pronunciation his success doesn't make
my efforts less enjoyable to me so we
all proceed in our own way and we can
all get to our goals so that's why I
wanted to do this video of course I'm
not Moses sorry to disappoint you and
the but thank you for listening and I
look forward to your comments bye for
now